herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen kollegen ich glaube es
ist höchste zeit dass wir in diesen
tagen die arbeit von betriebsräten ich
würde hinzufügen auch von personalräten
und werkstatt wegen in deutschland weil
als deutscher bundestag ordentlich
würdigen
denn das was betriebsräte
interessenvertreterin
interessenvertreter in diesen zeiten
leisten aber ganz grundsätzlich
das macht unser land stark betriebsräte
sorgen dafür die interessen von
arbeitnehmerinnen arbeitnehmern in
unternehmen wirksam zu vertreten wo
betriebsräte aktiv sind werden
arbeitsschutz regeln konsequent
eingehalten betriebsräte aktiv sind wenn
die interessen von beschäftigten
vertreten wenn es zum beispiel um
betriebsvereinbarung für mobiles
arbeiten des home office geht um
betriebsräte aktiv sind gibt es moderne
betriebsvereinbarung zum beispiel auch
für qualifizierung und weiterbildung
also meine damen und herren was
betriebsräte leisten ist für dieses land
unglaublich wichtig unsere soziale
marktwirtschaft unsere volkswirtschaft
aber ich will es auch nochmal sagen aus
der wirtschaftspolitischen perspektive
in meiner heimat kenne ich leider gottes
einige beispiele in denen unternehmen
gescheitert sind an kurzsichtigen
anteilseignern oder unfähigen management
aber ich kenne kein unternehmen in
meiner heimat das gehe an einem sturen
betriebsrat gescheitert es im gegenteil
meine damen und herren dienste
übernehmen nicht nur die
interessenvertretung sondern ganz oft in
vielen fällen den krisen und den change
prozessen auch co management funktionen
mittlerweile in deutschen unternehmen
und deshalb ist es höchste zeit dass wir
das betriebsverfassungsgesetz nach 20
jahren grundlegend erneuern und mit dem
gesetzentwurf den wir heute im deutschen
bundestag als bundesregierung einbringen
gibt es drei wesentliche fortschritte um
betriebsverfassung und mitbestimmung in
deutschland zu stärken erstens wir
brauchen in deutschland mehr
betriebsräte denn ich habe über die
guten beispiele gesprochen aber wir
haben viel zu viele bereiche die
betriebsrats freie zonen sind
und deshalb werden wir nicht nur die
gründung von betriebsräten erleichtern
und die wahl verfahren vereinfachen
wir wollen auch mut machen dass mehr
menschen ein betriebsrat gründen einen
betriebsrat zu gründen ist schon heute
ein gutes recht von arbeitnehmerinnen
und arbeitnehmern sogar ein
straftatbestand das zu unterdrücken aber
in der realität des lebens gibt es
einige schwarze schafe in unternehmen
die mit allen tricks und mitteln
menschen einschüchtern und meine
betriebsrats gründung zu verhindern auch
bei großen amerikanischen konzernen in
deutschland übrigens soll das
vorgekommen sein
deshalb stärken wir den kündigungsschutz
für diejenigen die tatsächlich einen
betriebsrat gründen wollen die
variationen
zweitens meine damen und herren
betriebsräte in deutschland brauchen
moderne arbeitsbedingungen die pandemie
hat uns gezeigt dass betriebsräte auf
der höhe der zeit arbeiten und auch
beschlüsse fassen müssen
deshalb werden wir dauerhaft das recht
schaffen betriebsratssitzung per video
und telefonkonferenzen auch beschlüsse
fassen zu können
die entscheidung darüber liegt aber beim
betriebsrat selbst um das ganz deutlich
zu sagen
drittens meine damen und herren ich habe
es vorhin gesagt brauchen betriebsräte
in betriebsräte in deutschland die
möglichkeit auch in zeiten des digitalen
und technologischen wandels auf der höhe
der zeit mitbestimmung ausüben zu können
und deshalb stärken wir nicht nur das
recht betriebsräte zu gründen sondern
wir stärken auch die rechte von
betriebsräten
das betrifft beispielsweise ein
initiativrecht von betriebsräten für
qualifizierung und weiterbildung damit
die beschäftigten von heute in diesem
wandel der arbeitsgesellschaft auch die
chance haben die arbeit von morgen zu
machen
beispielsweise indem wir ein neues recht
schaffen zur ausgestaltung von mobiler
arbeit für betriebsräte und
beispielsweise auch indem wir dafür
sorgen dass für den einsatz von
künstlicher intelligenz
mitbestimmungsrechte gestärkt werden und
das handwerkszeug der betriebsräte zur
verfügung steht auch in diesem bereich
mitbestimmen zu können wenn es
beispielsweise darum geht externen
sachverstand heranzuholen immer ein
beispiel sagen ki ist eine riesen chance
zur modernisierung unserer
volkswirtschaft künstliche intelligenz
aber falsch eingesetzt kann es die
rechte von beschäftigten tatsächlich
zerstören wenn es beispielsweise um
personal aus argentinien inzwischen auch
über künstliche intelligenz machen kann
die chance dass das
diskriminierungsfreie läuft aber falsch
gemacht kann es diskriminierung auch
noch verstärken
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
herr präsident die mitbestimmung ist
nicht nur eine gute tradition in
deutschland
als soziale marktwirtschaft die
mitbestimmung ist nicht nur ein stück
deutsche sozialstaat betriebsräte
arbeiten gemeinsam mit gewerkschaften
sind die lohn- und arbeitsbedingungen
und die zukunftsperspektiven von
beschäftigten in der regel besser und
deshalb braucht unser land mehr
mitbestimmung und nicht weniger was hat
auch eine dimension nicht nur für die
rechte der beschäftigten und für die
wirtschaftliche stabilität von
unternehmen in einem dramatischen
strukturwandel sondern es hat auch mit
demokratie zu tun meine damen und herren
in der bundesrepublik deutschland macht
bei uns demokratie nicht halt am
werkstor und wirtschaftsdemokratie ist
auch teil der sozialen marktwirtschaft
demokratie ist nicht nur parlamente und
räte sondern sind auch betriebsräte
deshalb herzlichen dank an die
betriebsräte in deutschland wir stärken
ihnen heute den rücken herzlichen dank
der bundesarbeitsminister hubertus heil
hat hier noch einmal die pläne
vorgestellt
der nächste redner in dieser debatte
kommt von der af d-jugend police
mitglied im ausschuss für arbeit und
soziales bildung
sehr geehrter herr präsident verehrte
kollegin werte arbeitnehmer im land die
fdp begrüßt ausdrücklich jeden
geeigneten vorschlag zur erleichterung
von betriebsratswahlen mit dem ziel zu
einer höheren akzeptanz in den betrieben
zu kommen und die arbeitnehmer insgesamt
mehr mut zu machen
eine arbeitnehmervertretung zu wählen es
müssen aber wirkliche erleichterungen
seien bei der alten leitung von walen
und vor allen dingen bei der
kandidatenaufstellung auch die
befugnisse der arbeitnehmer vertreter
müssen sich deutlicher an den wirklichen
interessen der arbeitnehmer orientieren
erstens geschlagen vor
vor allem für klein- und mittelbetriebe
die wahlen so genannten vereinfachten
verfahren durchzuführen hierzu gibt es
im bvg und in den wahlordnung schon
entsprechende bedingungen der
geltungsbereich sollte aber zwingend auf
betriebe mit bis zu 200 beschäftigten
ausgeweitet werden
das trägt auf alle fälle zu einer
beschleunigung und zur zusätzlichen
rechtssicherheit für die wahl des
betriebsrates bei konkrete vorschläge
seitens der haft liegen vor so viel hier
das papier sozialpolitische impulse
arbeit lau gedacht
[Applaus]
zweitens darüber hinaus forderung hier
eine erleichterung für alle arbeitnehmer
bei der aufstellung von kandidaten und
der benennung von wahlvorschlägen
gegenüber dem jeweiligen wahlvorstand
zwei unterstützungsunterschriften unter
einem oder mehreren kandidaten
vorschlägen müssen ausreichen für einen
gültigen und anerkannten wahlvorschlag
für die betriebsratswahl die
benachteiligung von arbeitnehmern
gruppierungen gegenüber einer
betrieblichen gewerkschaft ist durch
nichts rechtfertigen gewerkschaften
sollten gegenüber einzelnen
arbeitnehmern im betrieb keine
privilegien haben
schließlich geht es bei der
betriebsratswahl in aller erster linie
um eine wahl der arbeitnehmer und um
keine wahl von gewerkschaftlichen
vertrauensleute
oder sonstigen funktionär den solaris
sie die gründung innerhalb des
regierungsentwurfs herten höchster
geradezu eine bevormundung von arbeiten
jemand letztendlich unsinn
die arbeitnehmer entscheiden ganz allein
hier gewählt wird die bundesregierung
sollte also nicht den versuch
unternehmen in ihre gesetzesvorschläge
sogenannte gewerkschaftliche ideologien
zu übernehmen aber augenscheinlich
braucht minister heil für seinen
wahlkampf
das wohlwollen des dgb liebe kollegen
wir müssen auch über den tarif vorbehalt
sprechen wir fordern die in tariff
vorbehalt der gewerkschaften für die
regelung der arbeitsbedingungen
aufzuheben
auch betriebsräte sollten die
möglichkeit und die kompetenz bekommen
für die beschäftigten ihres
zuständigkeitsbereiches mit der
geschäftsleitung und dem arbeitgeber
verbindliche betriebsvereinbarung oder
eine vereinbarung für ein haus oder
firmentarifvertrag zu treffen
die afd die alternative für deutschland
ist die partei der arbeitnehmer und
steht für die interessen der
arbeitnehmer und nicht für die
interessen der alten gewerkschaften
kurzum arbeit von betriebsräten muss
wesentlich attraktiver gestaltet wir
haben gerade darin liegt die aufgabe des
gesetzgebers
der vorliegende entwurf der
bundesregierung bewegt sich viel zu sehr
in richtung bürokratie und technischen
vorgaben anstatt auf wirklich notwendige
beteiligung zur mitsprache rechte der
arbeitnehmer und ihrer betriebsräte zu
gehen die vorschläge der fdp sondern
dagegen einfachere und leichtere
durchführungsbestimmungen für
betriebsratswahlen und räumen die im
betrieblichen arbeitnehmervertretern
auch wichtige zusätzliche kompetenzen
und gestaltungsmöglichkeiten ein
dankeschön
[Musik]
die us regierung möchte mit dem
gesetzentwurf die gründung von
betriebsräten erleichtern unter anderem
einen verbesserten kündigungsschutz
demnach soll das kündigungsschutz bis
gab es bisher pardon für den ersten drei
personen die zu einer betriebsratswahl
einluden
künftig sollen es dann sechs personen
seien und auch schon vor einer einladung
wenn mitarbeiter über eine
betriebsratswahl nachdenken und diese
plan soll kündigungsschutz gelten gut
der nächste gegner jetzt wo wir schon
mal
sie haben ein problem mit den
demokratischen parteien sie haben ein
problem mit den kirchen sie haben ein
problem mit den gewerkschaften sie haben
probleme mit den sozialverbänden
irgendwann werden sie begreifen nicht
wie kirchen und gewerkschaften sind das
problem
sie sind das problem aus der
betriebsräte gesetz ist das ungefähr 100
jahre alt es war ein katholischer
priester aus essen aus dem ruhrgebiet 30
arbeitsminister heinrich brauns der
dieses betriebsräte gesetz 1920
durchgesetzt hat und zwar aus der senke
heraus was wir eben sagen auch
solidarität zwischen unterschiedlichen
kräften interessengruppen auch eine
partnerschaftliche eine konsenskultur
ist das kontrastprogramm zu den konflikt
ideologie in jener zeit und auch dieser
zeit egal ob sie es den klassenkampf auf
der einen seite oder den rassen kampf
auf der anderen seite propagieren wir
wollen das miteinander und füreinander
der verschiedenen kräfte und das
spiegelt sich im betriebsräte gesetz
traditionell immer wieder dass wir nach
100 jahren auch ein update der
betrieblichen mitbestimmung brauchen und
dass mitbestimmung auch kein schönwetter
konzept ist sondern gerade in
schwierigen zeiten sich immer wieder
bewährt hat ist offenkundig und es
stimmt wir wollen zwei linien dann auch
verfolgen zum einen wir wurden mehr
betriebsräte wir wollen die erosion der
betriebsräte in den unternehmen beenden
wir sehen dass viele neue unternehmen
diese mitbestimmungs kultur eben nicht
aufgenommen haben und deshalb wollen wir
schauen dass wir diese mitbestimmung
auch wieder modernisieren und mehr
betriebsräte bilden dazu hilft ein
einfaches wahlverfahren dass man also
nicht kompliziert und über 6 8 wochen
hinweg mit so vielen
unterstützungsunterschriften dann einen
betriebsrat bildet sondern dass man auch
bis 200 beschäftigte optional das
einfache wahlverfahren im grunde über
eine wahlversammlung in dem unternehmen
organisieren kann
wir wollen letztendlich auch deshalb
mehr betriebsräte weil die nahrungskette
eine selbststeuerung der wirtschaft
nämlich tarifautonomie auf der einen
seite betriebs partnerschaft auf der
anderen seite sorgt ja auch dafür dass
der staat sich wenige einmischen muss
und dort wo es betriebsräte gibt da ist
auch die tarifautonomie über 70 prozent
da wo es keine betriebliche
mitbestimmung gibt da liegt auch die
tarifbindung bei nur noch 25 prozent
deshalb ist die nahrungskette so
betriebliche mitbestimmung und dann auch
für tarifautonomie tarifautonomie
bessere löhne faire arbeit und das ist
eine nahrungskette die wir stärken
wollen dazu gehört auch in der sensiblen
phase bevor ein wahlvorstand gebildet
wird auch den kündigungsschutzes war
verstandes auf die initiatoren wenn die
sich in einer protokollerklärung dann
auch dafür aussprechen
das waren den ausweitet damit hier da wo
10 15
nach untersuchungen sagen da wird
gemobbt da wird gekündigt da wird
gestört damit ein betriebsrat nicht
gebildet werden kann eine minderheit der
unternehmen aber es gibt sie zehn bis 15
prozent
und da müssen wir die schutzbestimmungen
ausweiten das haben wir mit einem sehr
einfachen konzept das auch von der
arbeitnehmergruppe seit drei jahren
innerhalb der unionsfraktion propagiert
wird nämlich durch neutrale stelle
protokollerklärung und dann die
ausweitung der schutzbestimmungen für
die vorfeld initiatoren wir wollen nicht
nur mehr betriebsräte das heißt wir
wollen auch schauen dass wir die alters
können sie für die jugend und
auszubildendenvertretung 'nen die 1993
als bundesvorsitzender der jungen cdu
noch nicht durchgesetzt habe
parlamentarisch mit bernd rützel und das
waren die 90er ist kommen die veteran
geschichten aber wir wollen natürlich
wenn junge menschen immer später in die
ausbildung gehen dass dann auch mit 25
jahren und darüber hinaus und im dritten
lehrjahr sind sie mit wählen können und
das junge arbeitnehmer auch ein
doppeltes wahlrecht haben nämlich für
die jugend und auszubildendenvertretung
also für den betriebsrat wir wollen aber
nicht nur mehr wir wollen auch moderne
betriebsräte und deshalb ist es gut dass
wir jetzt für die erfahrung der pandemie
nämlich auch betriebs ratssitzungen dann
über videokonferenzen zu organisieren
dass wir ein stück weit auch sagen bei
künstlicher intelligenz balkan muss dann
auch wenn entsprechend die beschäftigten
und die arbeitsablauf organisation
betroffen ist dass man mit mit ständigen
sachverständigen arbeiten kann und dass
sie dann auch ein stück weiter die
betriebsratsarbeit begleiten
das sind themen die wir die hilfreich
sind die wichtig sind wir wollen also
mehr betriebsräte wir wollen das moderne
betriebsräte dafür setzen wir uns ein
sagt nur wir schon mal von der cdu die
fdp stellt hier einen antrag und setzt
sich für den betriebsrat 4.0 ein
potenziale der digitalisierung nutzen
betriebs arbeit soll laut fdp generell
digital gestaltet werden können so dass
die betriebsräte auch dauerhaft und
rechtssicher mittels video und
telefonkonferenzen erarbeiten und auch
beschlüsse auf diesem weg gefasst werden
können karl julius kronberg für die fdp
ist hier der nächste redner ist der sohn
von julius kronberg der mal bundestags
vizepräsident war
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die
bundesregierung verfolgt einerseits dass
sie die gründung von betriebsräten zu
fördern und andererseits die rolle
bestehende betriebsräte zu stärken so
weit so gut
der interne abstimmungsprozesse zum
gesetzentwurf hat im wesentlichen zu
einer neue plakatierung geführt aus der
betriebsräte stärkung gesetzt wurde dass
betriebsräte modernisierungsgesetz liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wenn die
namensgebung im zentrum der beratungen
gestanden hat sein - wohl weniger um den
inhalt des gesetzes als um die wahlkampf
deutlichkeit der verpackung und das
kritisieren wir dabei ging es dabei gibt
es ohnehin zweifel bedarf an
modernisierung und niemand kann sich
freuen dass betriebliche mitbestimmung
insbesondere in betrieben zwischen 50
und 500 beschäftigten seit jahren auf
dem rückzug ist stellt sich die frage
warum gibt es eigentlich zu wenig
interesse an der gründung eines
betriebsrats zu wenig bewerber für den
betriebsrat
sie stellen im gesetz den bewussten
verzicht auf einen betriebsrat seitens
der belegschaft auf eine stufe mit der
bewussten verhinderung der gründung
durch die arbeitgeber
dabei wissen sie genau dass
hunderttausende von betrieben
schlichtweg keine notwendigkeit sehen
weil sie vertrauensvoll und
partnerschaftlich mit der
geschäftsleitung zusammen arbeiten
insbesondere scheine betrieb
demgegenüber stehen nur handverlesene
einzelfälle eine arbeitgeberseitigen
behinderung das ist strafbewehrt und das
ist sehr sehr schlimm und jeder einzelne
fall ist einer zu viel aber hier den
eindruck zu erwecken es handle sich um
ein massenphänomen ist mit verlaub
unredlich vielmehr ist die betriebs
arbeit überreguliert und bürokratisch
warum können beschlüsse nicht
elektronisch im umlauf gefasst werden
warum benötigen betriebsvereinbarungen
in zukunft eine qualifizierte
elektronische signatur dass es im
zweifel noch hinderlicher als die
übliche schriftform ihr bürokratismus
steht der gründung von betriebsräten
definitiv mehr und öfter im wege als
mitbestimmungs feindliche arbeitgeber
liebe koalition von cdu und spd nehmen
wir nehmen wir die ausweitung des
sogenannten vereinfachten verfahrens
ganz ehrlich ihr vereinfachtes verfahren
ist immer noch weit komplizierter als
die wahl eines bundestagskandidaten oder
eines bundesvorsitzende in einer partei
und das liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
von der cdu
wieso nicht gerade trivial wie sie
wissen es ist dringend erforderlich dass
betriebsräte elektronisch gewählt werden
können deshalb fordern wir genau das in
unseren antrag beim thema ausgestaltung
von home office wollen sie betriebsräten
mehr mitbestimmungsrechte einräumen
dabei wissen sie doch ganz genau dass
ihre ergänzung 14 in paragraf 87 absatz
1 nichts aber auch garnichts regelt was
nicht bereits in den sätzen 1 bis 13
geregelt ist liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen von der koalition dass es weder
stärkung noch modernisierung das ist
schlichtweg symbolpolitik der
gesetzgeber
der gesetzgeber ist gegenüber den
sozialpartnern zur neutralität
verpflichtet wenn es betriebliche
mitbestimmung stärken will muss ja sie
entbürokratisieren genau darauf zielt
unser antrag ab digitale waren sitzungen
im digitalen format bei ist das
geschehen gott sei dank digitaler
beschlussfassungen so lautet der
dreiklang der betriebsräte ins 21
jahrhundert trägt ich freue mich auf den
rat waren gemischt für die linke kriegt
jetzt das wort die sprecherin für
mitbestimmung und arbeit jutta krellmann
und die linke legt ebenfalls einen
antrag vor betriebliche mitbestimmung
ausweiten und moder modernisieren
die linke fordert in ihrem antrag eine
ausweitung der mitbestimmung denn die
finanzkrise 2008 9 haben mit bestimmte
betriebe sich viel besser erholt so die
argumentation vergessen sie aufzuziehen
abzuziehen auch als
gewerkschaftssekretärin habe ich über 25
jahre betriebsräte betreut
ich habe mit den kolleginnen gestritten
und gekämpft
ihre aufgabe ist darüber zu wachen dass
gesetze verordnungen und tarifverträge
eingehalten werden
starke betriebsräte schützen ihre
kolleginnen und kollegen und gestalten
veränderungen im betrieb im gesetz steht
in betrieben mit in der regel mindestens
fünf arbeitnehmer werden betriebsräte
gewählt
das ist gelebte demokratie
[Applaus]
aber nur noch neun der betriebe haben
einen betriebsrat 91% nicht nur 40
prozent der beschäftigten werden durch
einen betriebsrat vertreten 60 prozent
nicht dass kolleginnen und kollegen ist
eine katastrophe ich bin entsetzt wenn
ich höre dass abgeordnete über die
vorhandene soziale marktwirtschaft
schwadronieren
aber dieses problem ignorieren leider
wird auch der vorliegende
gesetzesentwurf der bundesregierung an
dieser entwicklung nichts grundsätzlich
ändern
das machen wir nicht mit wir brauchen
endlich eine echte eine echte
modernisierung des
betriebsverfassungsgesetzes von märz bis
mai 2000 22 22 werden wieder
betriebsratswahlen stattfinden und ich
muss ihnen sagen sehr geehrte
bundesregierung mit ihrem vorschlag
werden wir nicht mehr betriebsräte haben
über das vereinfachte wahlverfahren
wollten sie schon 2001 mehr betriebsräte
erreichen dass es doch gescheitert
warum soll denn jetzt durch die geplante
aus warum soll das jetzt so plante
ausweitung lingen
wir brauchen weitere punkte des st
die weiteren punkte des gesetzentwurfs
sind vielfache eine bestätigung sowieso
schon herrschender rechtsauffassungen es
und es gibt im übrigen auch keine
wirkliche stärkung der
mitbestimmungsrechte
sie haben keine innovative idee für den
start in die nächsten 50 jahre
wir haben in unserem antrag viele
konkrete vorschläge zur stärkung der
mitbestimmung gemacht aber die zentrale
frage ist wie es gelingt mehr
betriebsräte zu wählen
die linke sagt erstens das
arbeitsgericht kann direkt einen
betriebsrat einsetzen wenn wahlen
behindert werden
zweitens befristet beschäftigte haben
das recht auf einen unbefristeten
vertrag wenn sie in den betriebsrat
gewählt werden und schaffen sie endlich
sachgrundlose befristungen ab aber er
muss man einmal jährlich die
beschäftigten über ihre rechte aus der
durch das betriebsverfassungsgesetz
aufklären gewerkschaften sollen die
sitzungen leiten und dann können
beschäftigte informiert mit
betriebsratswahlen staaten wenn sie
wollen dass die rechte der beschäftigten
gestärkt werden dann stimmen sie uns zum
antrag zu vielen dank
der bundestag debattiert über die
betriebliche mitbestimmung ein
gesetzentwurf der bundesregierung sieht
unter anderem verbesserten
kündigungsschutz niedrige schwellen zur
aufstellung eines wahlvorschlags und
ausweitung der rechte von betriebsräten
vorbereitung oder gmx für bündnis 90 die
grünen sprecherin für arbeitnehmerrechte
aktive arbeitsmarktpolitik hat jetzt das
wort kolleginnen und kollegen
es ist gut das ist jetzt doch noch eine
reform der betrieblichen mitbestimmung
geben wird denn die weißen flecken bei
der mitbestimmung sind groß die
betriebsräte brauchen mehr schutz und
die mitbestimmung muss auch an die
digitalisierung und transformation
angepasst werden denn diese großen
herausforderungen können in den
unternehmen nur gemeinsam also mit den
beschäftigten und betriebsräten
bewältigt werden
und das funktioniert nur mit einer
mitbestimmung auf augenhöhe
[Applaus]
der gesetzentwurf ist zwar kein großer
wurf es gibt licht und schatten aber er
geht in die richtige richtung richtig
gut wirklich gut ist dass jetzt endlich
auch die beschäftigten schutz bekommen
die sich auf den weg machen um erstmalig
einen betriebsrat zu gründen das ist die
schwierigste phase vor allem in
unternehmen die mitbestimmungs feindlich
sind den schutz dieser aktiven
beschäftigten haben wir schon 2014
gefordert jetzt wird das umgesetzt und
das freut mich ganz besonders denn wenn
arbeitgeber betriebsräte verhindern
wollen dann müssen wir ganz eindeutig an
der seite der beschäftigten stehen im
gesetz fehlt aber mehr schutz für die
betriebsräte die sachgrundlos
befristeten sind sie haben aufgrund
ihres engagements in der regel keine
chancen übernommen zu werden und hier
fordern wir dass diese
arbeitsverhältnisse entfristet werden
gut wiederum ist dass es ein
mitbestimmungsrecht geben wird wenn es
um mobile arbeit geht das fördern wir
auch aber das reicht nicht wir brauchen
natürlich auch ein gesetz herr minister
im home office und und mobiles arbeiten
ganz grundsätzlich zu reden
auch das vorgesehene initiativrecht bei
der weiterbildung ist zwar gut aber zu
wenig die haus herausforderungen sind
groß und deshalb fordern wir ein echtes
mitbestimmungsrecht bei der qualitativen
personalentwicklung und wichtig wäre
natürlich auch ein digitales
zugangsrecht für die gewerkschaften das
müsste doch in einer digitalen
arbeitswelt selbstverständlich sein
und dann gibt es auch noch regelungen
die gar nicht gehen und zwar beim thema
datenschutz hier wird vom betriebsrat
unterstützung und zusammenarbeit
gefordert und damit ist die
unabhängigkeit des betriebsrats in
gefahr
das müssen sie die regierungsfraktion
wirklich noch
auf jeden fall verändern mein fazit ist
also hier in erster lesung die reform
ist wichtig die richtung stimmt im
gesetzentwurf gibt es alles von sehr gut
über schlecht bis hin zu geht gar nicht
nicht akzeptabel
sie sollten also noch einige stellen
verändern und verbessern ich freue mich
auf jeden fall auf die beratung im
ausschuss das wird kontrovers aber wir
werden wie immer konstruktive vorschläge
machen vielen dank land sicherlich gilt
auch hier bei der betrieblichen
mitbestimmung das strafgesetz kein
gesetzentwurf geht in den bundestag
hinein wie er hinterher wieder
herauskommen wird es wird sicherlich da
noch die eine oder andere veränderung
geben bernd rützel jetzt für die spd
bundestagsfraktion
heute ist ein wirklich guter tag für
alle betriebsrätinnen und betriebsräte
in unserem land und der hubertus heil
unser arbeitsminister der hat heute früh
in seiner rede den betriebsrätinnen und
räte nicht nur gedankt für ihre
hervorragende arbeit
er hat sie gelobt sondern hat einen
gesetzentwurf vorgelegt ein
gesetzentwurf wo wir die rechte stärken
wo wir sie modernisieren wo wir sie fit
machen für die herausforderungen und wo
wir auch dafür sorgen wie der kollege
uwe schummer gesagt hat dass noch mehr
betriebsräte gegründet werden können
denn das stärkt die tarifbindung das ist
wichtig liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
die jutta krellmann hat die zahlen von
kb betriebs panel genannt 9 prozent
aller betriebsrats fähigen betriebe
haben nur einen betriebsrat 91% nicht
nur 40 prozent aller beschäftigten
werden durch einen betriebsrat vertreten
woran liegt das wollen die menschen alle
keinen betriebsrat weil sie sehr
vertrauensvoll zusammenarbeiten lieber
karl julius grund berg oder
woran liegt das es liegt daran das mag
vielleicht sein dass es einzelfälle gibt
aber ich kenne auch sehr viele
da werden sie behindert sie werden
behindert mit allen mitteln versuchen
arbeitgeber dafür zu sorgen dass es
betriebsrats freie betriebe gibt dass
der betriebsrat nicht hoch kommt kennt
es aus meinem wahlkreis es gibt hier
viele viele beispiele und die jeder
kennt und deswegen können wir da nicht
zu gucken wir müssen an der seite derer
stehen die jetzt dafür sorgen dass die
leute die sich treffen
vorher treffen lang sich überlegen wir
brauchen doch mal ein betriebsrat dass
die nicht ausgeschlossen werden dass sie
nicht ausgehungert werden dass die durch
einen kündigungsschutz geschützt werden
und das machen wir mit diesem gesetz und
die vereinfachten wahlverfahren die
haben auch dazu beigetragen nachweislich
dass in diesen betrieben wo es die
vereinfachten wahlverfahren gibt die
wahlbeteiligung über zehn prozent höher
liegt wie in denen wo das nicht der fall
ist weil es schneller geht als kompakter
geht weil es besser läuft liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
wir weiten das verfahren aus wir senken
die schwellen was die unterschrift
sammlung betrifft und ich bin selber
froh auch dass die jugend und
auszubildendenvertretung 'nen gestärkt
werden dass die ausgeweitet werden es
ist nicht mehr so wie früher dass über
24 jährige einen anteil von zwei bis
drei prozent hatten in berlin zum
beispiel sind es derzeit 18 prozent die
menschen werden alle älter nicht mehr
wie vielleicht wir über schummer die mit
14 jahren an der werkbank standen heute
sind die menschen älter und ich habe mir
sagen lassen man kann auch noch eine
ausbildung machen wir mal 30 ist wenn
man 40 ist wenn man 50 ist man lernt nie
aus deswegen brauchen wir starke jugend
und auszubildendenvertretung billen
[Applaus]
voraussichtlich letzter redner in dieser
debatte ist der kollege stephan stracke
csu stimmen stracke der neue
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
der csu
herr präsident meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren ein herzliches grüß
gott betriebliche mitbestimmung und
tarifautonomie tragen wesentlich zum
wirtschaftlichen erfolg unseres landes
bei und sichern auch den sozialen
frieden soziale marktwirtschaft starke
sozialpartnerschaft setzt voraus dass
interessen gebündelt werden
auf betriebsebene auf ebene der branche
und branchenübergreifend dazu braucht es
starke arbeitgeberverbände und natürlich
auch gewerkschaften und so starke
sozialpartnerschaft setzt
gestaltungswillen und gestaltungskraft
voraus und diese fähigkeit brauchen wir
mehr denn jeden globalisierung
digitalisierung klimawandel erzeugen
eine unglaubliche dynamik und
beschleunigen veränderungsprozesse und
aufgabe von politik und
sozialpartnerschaft ist es gerade diese
veränderungsprozesse in geordneten
bahnen zu lenken gleichzeitig sehen wir
dass die kraft der sozialpartnerschaft
brüchig geworden ist die bindekraft von
tarifverträgen lässt nach und die
betriebliche mitbestimmung ist spürbar
schwächer geworden das wurde von meinem
vorredner beschrieben und wir wollen
genau diesen trend stoppen wir wollen
ihn umkehren wir wollen mehr
betriebsräte in deutschland und deswegen
wollen wir das vereinfachte
wahlverfahren bei der betriebsratswahl
ausweiten und damit die gründung von
betriebsräten fördern
ich finde es durchaus besorgniserregend
welche geringschätzung der betrieblichen
mitbestimmung zum teil entgegengebracht
wird nicht wenige meinen betriebsräte
seien nicht mehr zeitgemäß ist ein
überflüssig wie die des äussern haben
eine wesentliche fehleinschätzung denn
sie wissen nicht oder schätzen es falsch
ein welchen großen mehr
an akzeptanz und betriebsfrieden es
bedeutet wenn wichtige entscheidungen
zuvor im betriebsrat besprochen und dann
gemeinsam im betrieb auch umgesetzt
werden
die geringschätzung geht gar nicht und
erst recht nicht behinderung oder gar
verhinderung von betriebsratswahlen
deswegen sorgen wir für bessere
schutzmechanismen bei der
betriebsratswahl betreffend den
wahlvorstand und auch die vorfeld
initiatoren diese schutzmechanismen sind
zugleich ein klares stopp signal
gegenüber denjenigen arbeitgebern die
die gründung von betriebsräten
verhindern wollen und meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren die
arbeitswelt ist massiven veränderungen
ausgesetzt acht-stunden-tag
präsenzpflicht ruhezeiten diese
klassischen vorstellungen sind nicht
allein aber natürlich auch durch die
digitalisierung aufgebrochen
die beschäftigen wollen immer mehr
flexibilität sie fordern sie ein und
video und telefonkonferenzen gehören
eigentlich jetzt zumindest seit der
pandemie zum täglichen handwerkszeug und
deswegen führen wir das auch für die
betriebsratswahlen dauerhaft als option
zu bei den betriebsratsarbeit dauerhaft
als option zu den präsenz sitzungen ein
und heute haben wir uns ja an computer
smartphones und apps als unterstützer in
allen lebensbereichen längst gewöhnt
weiterer technischer fortschritt wird
dazu kommen darunter auch künstliche
intelligenz künstliche intelligenz
bedeutet eigentlich ein neues
handwerkszeug um arbeiten leichter und
effizienter zu machen
sie wird in vielen bereichen menschliche
arbeit verändern und zum teil auch
ersetzen und deswegen müssen wir chancen
und schutz in einklang bringen und die
frühzeitige einbindung von
arbeitnehmervertretungen ist dafür
wichtige stellen wir klar dass erhöht
vertrauen und akzeptanz bei der
einführung und anwendung von künstlicher
intelligenz intelligenz und das
notwendige handwerkszeug an die hand zu
geben ja darauf kann man dann auch
leichte leichter auf den externen
sachverstand zurückgreifen
das ist richtig
als flexibles arbeiten wird immer
wichtiger und stärker von den
beschäftigten eingefordert sie begreifen
das als flexibilitäts gewinn nicht als
bedrohung und mobiles arbeiten wird auch
nach der pandemie einen hohen
stellenwert haben
die entscheidung über die einführung von
mobile aber dies ist und bleibt aufgabe
des arbeitgebers bei der ausgestaltung
von mobile arbeit werden betriebsräte in
zukunft ein eigenständiges
mitbestimmungsrecht erhalten dass es
auch sachgerecht denn es geht darum
verbindlich und passgenau in den
betrieben zu regeln wie der einsatz von
mobiler arbeit funktioniert und dabei
auch die grenzen klar zu formulieren das
schafft schutz und rechtssicherheit für
alle beteiligten und deshalb schaffen
wir ein neues mitbestimmungsrecht bei
der ausgestaltung von mobile arbeit
mobile arbeit ist nicht risikolos es
gibt lücken gerade im
unfallversicherungsschutz und derzeit
sind wir im gespräch wie wir diese
lücken schließen können wir wollen das
als union war wird dazu beitragen wollen
den versicherungsschutz zu verbessern
betriebsräte haben eine wichtige
funktion dieses vorliegende
gesetzesentwurf stärkt unsere
betriebsräte in deutschland ich freue
mich auf die ausschussberatungen kann
jetzt schließt sich die aussprache